gone girl did you see it I did okay
thoughts on that a lighting of hog-wild
and surprise surprise surprise I liked
it very very much too long everything is
too long but it kept me and engaged me I
thought it was really a well-written
film first of all and full of surprises
and then twists and turns I thought it
was like a modern-day Hitchcock film and
the best sense of you know Hitchcock
some films and I'm ashamed to cite
Hitchcock the director without
mentioning the writer is in yet I too
can name all and well Patricia Highsmith
wrote some of his his at least the books
upon which the movies were based and I
think sometimes she might have written
some of his screenplays as well but the
point is I thought that GaN girl
engaged me immediately it truly truly
kept my attention earned my
consideration and that's unusual that's
unusual so with Rosamund Pike's
character again not normal not what we
would see every day her motives her
manipulations well you know hopefully
there's no spoilers
but you know well but there's the point
is there is logic it's crazy as she is
and as manages that there is a cruel
steady logic to what she does everything
kind of kind of fits and ultimately what
comes across is is just like with Tony
Soprano I mean Tony Soprano was as
different a character for me as it could
be on the planet I mean I'm a college
professor I'm a privileged advantaged
kid from New York and you know writer
and a professor and all of that as far
as you could get from Tony Soprano and
yet when I watched The Sopranos when I
see Tony Soprano
I see me I see a guy who has the same
arguments with his wife that I have with
my wife who has the same battles with
his
adolescent children as I have with my
adolescent children the truth is my kids
are the best kids in the planet and I
never had 20 minutes but also I don't
have a lot of cuff link with my bride
we're married 48 years so we must have
figured out something or other but the
point is that I see in a Tony Soprano
not a disconnect from me but I see a
connection with me ice I feel a sense of
sharing his pains and his drum is
because I'm familiar with them in my own
way my there's nobody nobody gets out of
here alive
you